[Musique]
auguste cool bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
c'est un écrivain
l'auteur de best-sellers
la flotte fantômes qui a exploré
la guerre que les états unis pour être
avec la chine dans les années
et je suis l'auteur aussi de contrôle
qui va être publiée bientôt en france je
suis obsédée par ce qui va arriver quels
sont les problèmes que la société va
voir qui peuvent être très importants
les grands conflits les grandes choses
et chaque matin en me réveillant
j'essaie de de décompresser dans la
finition et qui est il
écrit que peter singer
ce dossier pwc engagement un partenariat
qui dure depuis huit ans
autrefois j'étais un journaliste wall
street journal
c'était une de mes sources quand
j'écrivais sur des sociétés d'armement
des drones c'est sa zone d' expertise et
nous avons formé un partenariat à partir
de cette amitié quand j'ai quitté le
journalisme il ya une douzaine d'années
et puis voilà maintenant ça ça arrive à
l'usiné
on a décidé de vous faire venir ce soir
à cause de votre livre ghost fleet la
flotte fantômes qui est sorti en 2015 où
vous avez anticiper l'augmentation des
tensions entre les etats-unis la russie
la chine
on a décidé de vous faire venir parce
que en france
on vient se réveiller on a décidé
d'utiliser les capacités intellectuelles
de nos auteurs de science-fiction pour
faire de la prospective la première
question je vais vous poser c'est
pourquoi les états sont obligés d'avoir
recours aux auteurs de science-fiction
et ne pas reposer leurs capacités sur
leur propre cellule de prospective
en 2022 c'est une des façons les plus
importants de découvrir véritablement
l'avenir
précisément à l'avenir des conflits ce
que les écrivains particulièrement les
écrivains qui sont prêts à faire des
recherches et écrire des fictions basé
sur des fêtes c'est de mail mieux
comprendre tout ce qui se passe
dans les aspects de d'equipe homme robot
par une un robot c'est pour mieux
comprendre ce qui va se passer parce que
la chine est une nation qui est capable
de vaincre les etats-unis peut-être
parce que les écrivains peut faire de
mieux c'est de parler des choses dont
personne ne veut parler
le statu quo est souvent renforcés par
les think tanks par des rapports
gouvernementaux
c'est à sa place mais on est à un moment
où vous faites plus créatif il faut à
réfléchir 1 l'impensable comment
l'intégrer dans toutes les choses des
défenses la stratégie la communication
avec le public et leur faire comprendre
ce qui se passe dans le monde parce que
c'est jamais fait et trop de gens qui se
parlent à eux mêmes les romans que
j'écris avec le single c'est exactement
ce que j'essaie de faire
j'ai
une question c'est comment nous
analystes à votre avis avec votre
expérience on son arrivée à ne plus
pouvoir penser en dehors de la boîte
une simple question d'incitation et
aussi
le médium lui même l'idée que le médium
est le message vous savez ces marchés le
mac luhan qui avait mis ça sur la table
tout ce que vous avez le droit de faire
c'est de créer des powerpoint et quelque
part dans un sous-sol du pentagone c'est
très très difficile de faire introduire
des idées de rupture que votre patron
entre vrais inconvenable et quand vous
travaillez dans une organisation
officielle que ce soit la défense le
militaire ou de renseignement comment
est-ce qu'on peut sortir de ce silo ya
rien de mieux en fait qu'une caresse y
une histoire les humains sont câblées
comme des machines pour comprendre les
récits pour partager les récits que ce
soit écrit ou parlé peu importe mais
fondamentalement c'est vraiment plus de
chose de très humain est la raison pour
laquelle c'est très important aussi de
réfléchir à cette approche de façon non
officielle c'est qu'on a tellement de
changements technologiques
que ce soit les nouvelles formes
d'ordinateurs comme les ordinateurs
quantiques où des drones autonome
vraiment dans les sujets delà des
sciences cognitives sont en oublie
souvent et je vois que les gens le mans
tu le rates dans les conversations au
niveau officiel c'est qu'on va tous ses
vivres dans cet avenir en ces futurs
c'est un peu comme dans une communauté
de designers quand on essaie de
comprendre
de l'utilisation d'un
et le problème auquel les gens font face
et c'est comme ça qu'un bon écrivain
pense quand ils procèdent approche là
qu'est ce qui vous a conduit
je pense avant 2015 parce que vous avez
dû commencer à écrire ce livre avant
2015 qu'est ce qui vous a conduit à
anticiper l'augmentation des tensions
avec la russie
un travail de terrain c'est un travail
avec des sources ouvertes c'est un
travail avec des sources privées mais
dans un réseau personnel c'est votre
intuition c'est où c'est quelqu'un qui
vous a donné les informations parce
qu'il n'arrivait pas à les faire
comprendre à ses propres chefs
c'est tous ces éléments ensemble
peut-être pas le dernier mais
personne nous a dit plus ou moins quoi
écrire mais quand je réfléchis à ce qu
est un problème sur lequel ça vaut la
peine d'écrire un bouquin parce que ça
prend des années à écrire et ça engage
beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup de
travail les des risques on peut on peut
se rater et personne ne lira la flotte
fantôme sort a été plus facile d'écrire
un essai ça aurait été plus logique
quelque chose de plus rationnel mais
mes défis autour de ces questions qu'on
a rencontrés c'est que les les
américains ont sous-estimé la montée de
la puissance chez nous faisons
c'était très très impopulaire en
2013-2014 de parler de cela en public de
dire cela en public que la chine était
une menace une perspective analytique
c'était pas une conversation très très
accepter y
avait un officier de la marine qui
donnait des conférences en 2014 sur ce
sujet mais bon même si on avait cette
idée claire que la mairie devrait se
réorienter de l'europe centrale vers
l'asie pacifique c'est beaucoup plus à
faire qu'à dire mais pour en revenir à
l'origine de l'idée
lorsque il ya un consensus autour du
concept dans ce cas la chine
et c'était une nation que les états unis
pouvaient défaire pouvait 20
mais par exemple il n'avait pas encore
la connaissance des cerveaux
l'intelligence artificielle quand il ya
une inconscience et de là dessus je me
suis dit mais pourquoi est ce que tout
le monde veut croire à sa personne ne
regarde cette direction là pourquoi les
gens ne regardent pas dans l'autre côté
et
il fallait inverser
les hypothèses auxquelles les gens
croyaient le plus quand on a travaillé
sur la photo fronton il y avait cette
notion de suprématie technologique
était important à l'époque que les états
unis ne pensait pas un conflit mondial
au 21e siècle donc on a commencé à
réfléchir du point de vue chinois savez
c'est comme dans les jeux de guerre
games
quand on joue seulement de votre côté
simon fléchi seulement aux choses comme
vous avez été formé à le faire eh ben
vous allez rater à la façon dont
l'adversaire va exploiter vos propres
hypothèses et
est ce que c'est c'est
les les chinois ou les russes vont
chercher les occasions pour trouver
exactement
comment ils peuvent prendre les forces
de l'adversaire allait tourner en
faiblesse c'était une façon de
travailler un autre aspect c'était c'est
un thriller c'est un techno thriller
c'est un roman mais il ya des éléments
et des éléments qui sont très très très
claire entre est très vrai on voulait
être très transparent avec les lecteurs
de ce qu'on voyait tout est là mais il
faut les mettre ensemble voyez
utiliser un véhicule créatif pour le
faire un roman bien les nôtres et des
notes qui a beaucoup de notes dans ce
autant que dans un essai j'ai une
expérience intéressante j'étais en
géorgie pendant une conférence qu'on
avait
avec eux des officiers de l'infanterie
et puis je voyais
j'ai visité les sergents-chefs et
l'adjudant qui me faisait traverser le
champ
d'atterrissage 10
des parachutistes les regardez regardez
comment ces moyens je regarde regarde
j'ai regardé toutes les notes de bas de
page
c'est pour établir la crédibilité pour
un lecteur militaire moi je suis un
civil je suis un écrivain j'ai pas les
expériences des militaires mais j'ai un
intérêt dans ces histoires là et je
pense que il faut établir nos sources et
à carreaux prouver qu'on a fait nos
devoirs à la maison on a vraiment
rechercher la faire
peut-être que les militaires vont avoir
des conclusions différentes mais c'est
quelque chose de très important à faire
quand on écrit sur l'avenir
les gens pensent qu'ils doivent avoir
raison tout le temps quand on parle du
futur il veut être ce qui prédit
l'avenir je sais pas si c'est toujours
possible mais l'acte de le faire le
processus s'est véritablement très
quelque chose de vulnérable parce que
même si on n'a pas des prédictions très
juste
au moins si vous avez véritablement si
vous sortez centre au sortir de votre
zone de confort eh bien ça peut refléter
la réalité de l'avenir
je vais reprendre le début de votre
réponse
on me dit j'ai parfaitement compris que
les américains ou l'armée américaine
n'avait pas anticipé la menace chinoise
c'est bon c'est vrai parce que j'ai bien
compris
moi je vais me positionner en avocat du
diable est ce que vous connaissez la
sécurisation du collier de perles par la
marine américaine
accordée les perdre
il
si pâle et un route énergétique chinoise
est ce que vous pensez pas que soit
l'armée américaine ne sait pas ce
qu'elle fait et créer ses propres démons
ou soit elle sait pertinemment ce
qu'elle fait est qu'elle a pertinemment
dissiper la menace chinoise selon elle
en sécurisant la capacité de couper la
route énergétique et commerciale
chinoise
donc vous n'avez peut-être est-ce que
vous pensez avoir des lunes et
round à un seul coup sûr que certaines
parties des militaires américains à
l'époque
2014 2015 2016 étaient très concentrés
sur ce type de choses sur ces sujets
l'accès aux ressources toutefois
un des plus grands défis à y réfléchir
les conflits dont on parle c'est que on
peut avoir une certaine partie de la
force unilatéralement qui comprend le
problème mais si à l'échelon politique
ils ne prennent pas ça au sérieux si le
mandat n'est pas de donner pour
accepter la menace parce que ça
déstabilise les relations commerciales
les relations diplomatiques alors c'est
une situation très difficile au niveau
stratégique national parce qu'il ya une
déconnexion entre les deux
c'est les plans les plans militaires
sont élaborés ils sont et on
comprenne beaucoup beaucoup des
possibilités mais agir sur le plan
national avant que cela soit nécessaire
et c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
dans nos projets c'est d'utiliser pour
créer une conscience pour dire vous
pouvez penser qu'il ya des choses
inévitable qui sont à 10 12 15 ans
d'aujourd'hui mais il faut faire
semblant ou disons faut vous préparer
c'est beaucoup plus proche que ça arrive
beaucoup plus tôt parce qu'on contrôle
pas
l'avant ce que ce soit leurs ambitions
stratégiques de la chine leur ambition
dans le monde et la russie cela bon
exemple avec l'ukraine la chine aussi
c'est un très bon exemple
sa transformation en cours des quatre
dernières années pour avoir une vision
qu'ils soient plus
claires sur le plan interne et ce plan
externe je crois que c'était
réconciliation est difficile à faire
donc il faut trouver de nouvelles façons
de le faire
vous me parlez de légion politique
quel regard vous portez sur le conflit
irakien le conflit afghan
ce qui s'est passé sur place comment ça
a été annoncé je reprends l'exemple de
collines powel avec la fausse anthrax ou
la vraie-fausse anthrax houle à
l'anthrax neutraliser ou la poudre de
perlimpinpin la farine ce que vous
voulez les armes de destruction massive
qu'on n'a jamais retrouvé comment vous
en tant qu ancien journaliste analyste
vous êtes et américains vous analysez le
conflit irakien qu'est ce qui s'est
passé comment ça s'est terminé
et les autres expéditions punitives que
les états unis ont pu faire dans le
monde pour apporter la démocratie pour
les petites filles et ainsi de suite
cette question
mais en sept ans j'étais à chicago j'ai
travaillé dans ça
un bâtiment de marché
et je regardais les moniteurs de télé
qu'on avait sur sky news network
et
l'eau c'est de regarder toujours ça mais
on n'y fait pas toujours attention et à
un moment on a vu
un éclair de lumière parce que
qui sait se concentrait sur les deux
tours c'est le deuxième concerne du
compte quelque chose parce qu'il ya eu
vraiment un éclair blanc
lorsque l'avion a touché la deuxième
tour et lorsque l'image il ya eu un zoom
arrière on a compris mieux ce qui se
passait
et chaque américain moments
qui peuvent
semer mort et s'armer maurice là pour ce
choc je pense que l'arrêt à lille le
réponse militaire était
une réaction naturelle normale tenté de
poursuivre les gens qui avait perpétré
cette attaque
quand on regarde l'invasion en irak et
la politique
le positionnement une des choses qui
étaient vraiment très très embêtante à
l'époque c'était que
des communautés différentes à washington
avait des raisons différentes
qui des réponses différentes pour la
raison d'aller en guerre la raison
c'était bon il y avait la nouvelle
composition par exemple d'apporter la
liberté la démocratie la réaction et moi
en tant que journaliste c'était vraiment
très embêtant qui avait tellement de
d'incohérences
ça veut pas dire que les gens ça faisait
pas de sens qui disait mais je réfléchis
à 7 ans en temps il faudra se poser la
question toujours quand on fait
maintenant avec l'ukraine et la russie
quand on devra le faire avec la chine et
taïwan et potentiellement ou avec un
autre lieu du pacifique est-ce qu'on a
confiance dans nos leaders politiques
pour la décision de prendre une nation
de la mener à la guerre
c'est pas simplement la question de ma
population les américains mais aussi nos
alliés et de réponses diffèrent il faut
que tout le monde comprenne et dans mon
cas c'était quand on allie ce qui se
passe et quand on a vu ce qui s'est
passé en irak et en afghanistan on
aurait dû anticiper et c'est très
douloureux pour mes amis qui ont passé
leur carrière là dedans qu'anticipé quoi
anticiper le mensonge pour les faire
tomber saddam hussein
anticipé que je comprends pas votre
réponse
parlant de l'afghanistan et à comprendre
la chute du pays dans les mains des
talibans la rapidité avec les ça s'est
produit
ça a pris énormément de gens par
surprise et seraient produits
sur la position des collines powell
intoxiquer avec un même à un mémo
d'étudiants sur le fait qu' il y avait
des armes de destruction massive en irak
vous en tant que journaliste américain
avec l'absolution historique de ce
mensonge d'état quelle est la perception
des américains sur ça ils ont
complètement oublié ils savent pas de
quoi c'était ils savent pas placer les
réactions une carte
c'était il fallait tuer lax du mal
quelle est la perception de la
population par rapport à ce mensonge
d'état
en 2022
c'est du passé c'est pas quelque chose
dont on parle dans les conversations
j'essaie de ramener l'idée que lorsque
l'état doit aller en guerre nous comme
américain on devra répondre à
ce qui a été fait et ce sera toujours
aussi pital lorsque l'on pense aux
conflits de l'avenir parce qu'une fois
qu'on
ya plus de
confiance c'est très difficile à
rétablir et encore aujourd'hui c'est de
plus en plus difficile de rétablir la
confiance parce qu'à tellement de
en fait tellement peu de confiance
dans les systèmes dans les organisations
dans le gouvernement
ça a duré deux décennies
mais ça s'est intensifié
et ça sent de plus en plus difficile est
ce qu une dation et qu'on peut appeler
ces gens à soutenir une opération comme
celle là une
nation occidentale un failli s'en
d'autres pays dans une très grave
question
qu'est ce que vous pensez du droit
international et du droit international
concernant la guerre est ce qu on doit
continuer à s' est à s'essuyer avec
est-ce qu'on doit remettre les
fondamentaux sur la table est-ce qu'il
faut réexpliquer aux états qu le
mensonge
c'est grave est ce qu'on doit
traduire en justice george bush
manants qui ne peut avoir une peau est
décédé donc c'est plus possible est ce
qu'on doit traduire en justice
un leader politique américain président
son état qui a menti et est-ce qu'il
faut traduire en justice tous ses
conseillers toutes les agences
nationales
tous les directeurs d'agencés nationales
qui ont supporté ce crime de guerre et
les crimes de guerre inhérents à
l'invasion irakienne
non non à l'antenne
j'ai bien essayé par la cour pénale
internationale c'est ça
sent bon non je pense pas que ce serait
bon de le faire aux dirigeants
américains au haut niveau gouvernemental
non qu'est ce que vous pensez de
collatéral des mages et ce qui est
assorti wikileaks concernant les crimes
de guerre américains
raison les tortures abou ghraib les
irakiens déguise en sapin de noël avec
des guirlandes guirlandes électriques et
des cagoules
la torture qu'est ce que vous pensez
tout ça en tant qu'américain
prospectiviste ayant les mains dans ce
genre d'affaires est-ce que c'est
nécessaire de comprendre la psychologie
de chaque côté pour pouvoir faire des
prêts des anticipations plus précise si
on sait qu'une puissance a tendance à
mentir est ce qu'il faut le prendre en
considération quand on établit une
prospective
vous savez en ce qui concerne notre
vraiment se reconnaître le passé pour la
vie
avec une organisation
comme wikileaks qui a totalement changé
le débat aux états unis avec des preuves
de première main rouge et d'abou ghraïb
et des choses de ce genre avec les
victimes collatérales
j'essayais de dépasser cela ça a changé
la façon dont le pays ne
nous perçoit
alors ce qui concerne les perspectives
de l'avenir sachant que ça fait partie
du conflit que ça se produit c'est pas
le produit de l'imagination de quelqu'un
et le public le scène grâce à wikileaks
grâce à julian assange
mais c'est pas c'est pas une abstraction
on peut lire une histoire mais on peut
le voir aussi on peut voir les rapports
originaux on peut regarder une vidéo
d'une vedette qui qui qui touche une
cible ces nouveaux paradigmes ce nouveau
modèle qui va continuer donc la capacité
des dirigeants de mentir c'est
extrêmement important au sujet de ce qui
peut se produire dans l'avenir
il faut prendre ça en compte l'aspect
humain la nature du pouvoir la nature
dans la façon les gens jouent avec le
pouvoir
la façon dont il ya toujours un élément
politique dans la guerre qui est
toujours un élément intérieur à cela
est ce que vous connaissez le général
wesley clark
d'analystes sont là je te connais qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette personne est
ce que c'est une source fiable est-ce
qu'il a déjà menti ou est ce que c'est
un vrai bon militaire américain droit
dans ses bottes carrées dans sa tête
exclure beaucoup d'expérience à lire
page les jamais rentrés wesley clark
banks aib mais dur de me prononcer c'est
une question de génération
il était commandant en europe et moi
j'ai pas une opinion déterminé à son
sujet j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
là-dessus je n'ai jamais rencontré
jamais travaillé avec lui comment vous
approchez vos sources de première main
votre éditeur m'a dit que vous aviez des
sources de première main directement au
pentagone c'est eux qui vous approche
qui vous tamponne c'est eux qui viennent
ou c'est vous qui les chassent et est ce
que vous faites l'anaconda autour de vos
futures sources connaissait la technique
de l'anaconda lit et d'ailleurs a été
mise en place en irak avec le succès
qu'on connaît
est ce que vous faites ça avec vos
sources est ce que voulait chasser vous
attendez qu'elle vienne à vous
c'est tellement de temps de ma vie en
tant que journaliste à apprendre à
parler aux gens et à voir que les gens
me parlent
gagner leur confiance et ça me met
beaucoup en tant que écrivains de
fiction
parce que quand j'ai quitté mon travail
wolseley john a pour utiliser la fiction
en tant qu'écrivain j'ai eu cette
expérience très intéressante par rapport
puisque le wall street journal aux etats
unis c'est un joueur extrêmement
prestigieux dans le monde de la presse
américaine et washington c'est un lieu
où votre titre est important si vous
voulez faire quelque chose à washington
la première des choses qu'on vous disait
tu travailles ou donc c'est très
important
donc j'ai quitté ce cet emploi
et quand j'étais là tout le monde me dit
waouh
en fait
je pensais que je sois quelqu'un je
serai monsieur personne à qui personne
ne parlerait parfois j'ai dû chasser les
gens les gens voulaient pas toujours me
parler et ça l'est et quand j'ai quitté
le journal
la chose la plus intéressante
qui t'arrive et c'est que les gens m'ont
dit ça enfin on peut te parler
et c'était vraiment un développement
intéressant parce que
avec le temps de trois ans je vais
quitter le journalisme depuis trois ans
à cause de l'intensité du travail on
parle tellement aux gens on a besoin
toujours de quelque chose tout de suite
et on a besoin de publier tout de suite
et les gens veulent pas vous le donner
et donc
en étant suffisamment crédibles et
loyale dans la façon dont je faisais mes
reportages et mes papiers même dans les
dents les dans les dents les
informations de
quand on s'occupait de gens qui donnent
et des fausses informations c'est
difficile parfois de développer des
relations de confiance
et vous voulez être la personne qui
lorsque quelque chose de méchant de
mauvais arrive vous l'êtes la première
personal savoir donc il faut développer
ce champ de relation
et donc
vous savez dans le dans les livres c'est
très important les notes de bas de page
ou les notes de fin de chapitre il faut
toujours avoir les les bonnes sources il
faut bien avoir aussi l'élément humain
en main
au niveau entrepôt logique il faut
connaître
comment faire passer la réalité de
quelqu'un il faut vraiment savoir
comment se mettre à la place de
quelqu'un pour bien expliquer ce qu'il
fait ce qu'il dit et moi j'ai fait ça
avec beaucoup d'humilité
et je crois que c'est excessivement
important ne jamais être de dans une
situation vous dites à quelqu'un comment
il doit être dans et si vous voulez
savoir ce qu'est l'avenir et bien il
faut être très humble de ce point de vue
là dire dire à quelqu'un comme il doit
être c'est très américain de faire ça
non
c'est un grand pays d'amérique et
beaucoup de gens différents
mais de faire bien ce travail
allez dans les lieux au moins j'étais
introduit que ce soit ou dans le monde
de la sécurité où il y avait des gens
qui n ont plus d'expérience que moi
comprendre ce que moi je peux apporter à
ce débat ces discussions être clair avec
moi là dessus comprendre aussi ce qu'ils
avaient à offrir quelque chose de très
important ce qui est important dans
l'idée que vous avez mentionné ce qu'il
faut chasser les gens pour avoir des
informations est ce qu ils viennent vers
moi il ya des moments où
on tente de décrire
qu'est ce que c'est que de voler sur un
f 45 par exemple moi je suis pas un
pilote j'ai jamais été un siège de
pilote
donc il faut aller faire une certaine
communauté rêve 35
essais l'avion qui est peint qui qui est
invisible sous la pluie cessa
fut invisible c'est
plus d'avions invisible danse existe
plus
ils sont tous sur les radars
on est tu as les verres de contact des
gens qui avaient volé sur ce genre
d'avion pour avoir un petit peu de
perspectives on fait très attention sur
savoir quel est le niveau de secret
parce que je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
vont pas nous parler de choses au delà
de ce niveau
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que d'être
poursuivi par missile qui sait je sais
qu'il va me taper mais quand vous ne
fait plus confiance à l'avion dans
lequel vous êtes en train de piloter et
soudain une seconde vous vous rendez
compte que c'est la plus grande des
probabilités de tout ce que vous allez
mourir c'est très très difficile à
écrire à décrire ça en tant que
quelqu'un finit pas dans les herbes dans
la sphère et on essaie de le faire
c'est vraiment une partie extrêmement
importante pourquoi on fait ce travail
avec l'internet avoir écrit la flotte
fantômes avant écrit contrôle qui a paru
aux états unis en 2020 les gens viennent
de plus en plus vers nous pour parler
questionné l'environnement de l'avenir
ces conversations sont de plus en plus
facile chaque année
une autre façon d'y penser à ce projet
c'est que
toute personne est une expérience quand
on a écrit la flotte fantôme on savait
pas qui allait le lire comment ils
allaient le recevoir c'est ce roman
on pensait à tom clancy de 1,86
c'est un titre différent fall est au
rouge l'alerté rouge
ça valait la peine de prendre le risque
avec contrôle de prix un livre écrit un
bouquin c'est pas une guerre avec la
chine non c'est pas ça du tout c'est à
washington c'est une histoire de
contreterrorisme on va venir sur les
histoires d'intelligence artificielle de
temps
mais je veux dire simplement que chaque
projet est une expérience nouvelle pour
nos c'est pas une interview à
l'américaine c'est une interview la
française c'est super ça ressemble un
peu à un interrogatoire
je suis en train de voir que vous simon
mais vers votre livre mais revenons à la
guerre ou l'anticipation de la guerre
quel est votre prospective pour les deux
années à venir les deux années qui vient
qui viennent ils viennent
vous avez appris le français j'ai passé
une année lyon et puis quand j'avais 20
ans ça fait beaucoup de temps
d'autrefois sont errobi ou durant
l'hiver feel better nous sommes un petit
peu je vais continuer à l'anglais
j'ai beaucoup d'inquiétude au cours des
deux années à venir
particulièrement au sujet de ce qui se
passe en ukraine une des choses qui
m'inquiètent c'est l'idée du récit
national
je parle du récit russes et
les années qui lui restent le pouvoir
qu'il a l'argent qu'il a amassés c'est
l'homme le plus riche du monde
probablement il a beaucoup à perdre
personnellement mais il n'a rien à
perdre sur le plan national
il n'aimait inquiétudes c'est qu'une des
plus grandes expériences qu'il a mené
avec l'invasion de l'ukraine il a tenté
de le faire mieux avec une campagne
d'information qui a complètement raté
cet objectif c'était de fracture et
l'europe l'otan particulièrement
l'objectif supposé par vous
c'est mon analyse c'est ce que je retire
de cela il ya des gens qui sont beaucoup
plus experts que moi sur la russie bien
sûr un poids de claire là-dessus mais je
suis mon instinct
il a encore des leviers qui lui reste
pour atteindre ses buts
ses campagnes d'information et de guerre
de l'information ne fonctionne pas au
titre
la tentative de fracture et
l'alliance de l'otan sa raté mais
exemple
frapper
une source disciple de l'otan en pologne
où il ya déjà plein par exemple ou
un autre pays qui tentent de rejoindre
l'otan
fracturé le temps c'est de cette façon
de décider de ce que sera véritablement
l'alliance
de mes plus grandes surprises c'était
qu'est-ce que vous surprendre sont
des choses qui m'a surprise c'est
l'unité de l'europe et aussi l'unité
avec le royaume uni et les etats unis
dans la fourniture des armes la
fourniture de ressources
il ya eu pas de fracturation de cela
mais c'est encore très tôt dans ce jeu
et on n'est pas passé par l'hiver
on sait toujours pas ce qu'il va se
passer
en automne sur le plan stratégique les
deux années à venir me semble très
importante du point de vue des six mois
à venir parce qu'en attendant chez jean
ping lui peut avoir un objectif
de prendre taïwan si 2027
quel que soit le la date en fait laissé
place et il écoute il apprend à quel
point l'amérique est engagé vis-à-vis de
ses obligations de défense européenne et
en même temps en créant des nouvelles
organisations de défense dans le
pacifique avec l'australie on dit qu'un
bon analyste un bon prospectiviste on
doit être capable de penser contre lui
même on va faire une expérience de
pensée vous ou moi je vais vous demander
de penser contre vous même face à la
prospective que vous devenez me dresser
concernant ce qu'il ya dans la tête de
poutine ses capacités ainsi de suite
maintenant je vais vous demander de
penser contre vous même et de me donner
votre nouvelle prospective
ce soit fait avec petter on se rencontre
comme ça
être de l'autre côté de la table par
rapport à ce que je viens de dire
est bien une des façons de le faire
c'est si poutine en fait
un penser contre vous même par rapport à
la prospective que vous devez me vous
venez de me dresser mais côté américain
quels sont les objectifs américains
qu'elle est quelles sont leurs capacités
d'organisation à long terme vous parliez
tine qui s'est préparé pendant des
années et ainsi de suite ok maintenant
je veux la prospective côté américain
ouais c'est à dire pourquoi elles
qu'elles sont quels sont les intérêts
américains
me faites pas croire que c'est encore
pour apporter la démocratie pour les
petites filles pour sauver la veuve et
l'orphelin parce que maintenant ça
marche pas du tout
s'apprend pu en europe d'accord donc
donnez moi votre prospectives concernant
les intérêts américains parce que quand
moi en tant qu'analyste
j'analyse ce qui se passe les sanctions
énergétiques que l'europe impose c'est
se tirer une balle dans le pied donc
est-ce que les américains je vais je
vais voler peut-être les mots de la
bouche est ce que les américains ont un
intérêt à ce que les européens se tire
dans le pied dont l'échiquier
international en termes de guerre
économique
parce qu'il faut toujours penser avec
plusieurs facettes dans son prisme de
lecture vous êtes d'accord avec moi je
vous écoute à des sons les intérêts
américains
je crois qu'on est dans un territoire
non cartographié
dans ce domaine de guerre économique et
du point de vue américain
il faudra en venir au fait qu'on est
déconnecté déconnecté avec la russie de
l'ouest et on ne sait pas encore on sera
notre relation avec l'europe mais
les intérêts de l'américain sont
concentrés de façon
très claire sur l'asie-pacifique
conserver la chine dans
l'enclos
l'australie
se rendre compte que le ca est de plus
en plus importante pour nous du point de
vue là notre projection vers l'avenir
quand on regarde des ambitions chinoises
pour
les routes de la soie par exemple faut
se comprendre que la tradition
de divisions américaines n'est plus
exactement un jour il faut comprendre
exactement comment contrer la vision
chinoise
il faut se concentrer sur cette notion
de
est-ce que c'est économique politique ou
est-ce que c'est du pouvoir du rpt pur
et dur qu'est ce que c'est plus investir
dans la défense c'est vraiment une des
questions pendantes c'est comment est-ce
qu'on va contrer la chine l'économie
chinoise est plus importante que celle
de n'importe quelle nation du monde les
dépenses militaires
deviendront plus importante que les
nôtres à la fin de cette décennie les
militaires seront plus professionnel
c'est des applications aussi au sein de
la chine mais c'est une autre discussion
mais ce sont les questions américaines
pour l'instant c'est très difficile d'en
parler
quelle nation peut être l'amérique
lorsque la chine sera plus forte
économiquement ce qui n'a jamais produit
pour nous et qu'est-ce qu'on sera encore
capable sur le plan militaire est
cependant la défense et je vous rappelle
que votre pays à 200 ans
la chine en admis
le chine est très énervé est ce qu'avec
ce que les anglais n'auront fait je
pense qu'une thérapie psychologique au
fait
vous êtes des adolescents prépubères
face à la chine non
dans un récit national
ce qui me fascine sur cette question de
l'histoire et d'héritage la chine est
vraiment la colère sur les guerres de
l'opium
le convoi d'une très jeune le parti
communiste est très très jeune il a été
formé en 2002 en 1928 la nation est née
la nation moderne de chine est né en
1948 une des choses qui maintiennent
assez
quelle est la durée de survie du parti
communiste chinois il ya tellement de
contradictions dans cette société en
partie
à cause de la croissance technologique
les militaires sont plus en plus fort le
parti communiste va vivre des moments
très difficiles
et
c'est à plus de sens à diriger le pays
pour le
le parti communiste chinois dirigé
une économie qui ne répond plus la
planification centralisée que peut vous
arrêter je voudrais avoir le même
raisonnement sur les états unis vingt
ans on va faire abstraction que vous
soyez américain jusqu'entre analystes
aucune nationalité contre ce qui compte
c'est la prospective pur je voudrais
avoir le
réévaluation des intérêts vitaux des
états unis dans votre bouche quels sont
les intérêts vitaux des états unis
quelle est la capacité des états unis à
survivre si l'hégémonie du dollar ça
fonctionne plus quelle est la capacité
des états unis à survivre s'il ne
contrôle plus les marchés financiers qui
est la capacité des états unis à
rayonner s'ils ne sont plus la première
armée du monde et si la monnaie du monde
n'est plus la leur
quels sont les intérêts vitaux des états
unis sauvegarde
des intérêts vitaux
face à la croissance chinoise comment
maintenir l'économie mondiale et les
réseaux économiques et culturels ouverts
c'est probablement la chose la plus
importante que les avions doivent faire
repousser cet aspect de la montée
chinoise nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de d'avoir à se combattre avec
eux à combattre avec contre eux parce
que notre pays est trop petit c'est
bizarre à dire des états unis
intellectuellement parlant
non pas simplement intellectuellement
économiquement
comme centre d'innovation et ça fait
partie de cette vision je parle de
philosophie panier
d'amérique perd sa capacité d'être le
lieu et ça semble un cliché où les gens
les plus intelligents du monde veulent
venir être libre et faire de l'argent
ben là on sera très très mal non ça
c'était trop extrémiste est trop violent
trop dysfonctionnelle ça ne signera pas
c'est peut-être
un détail pour
l'instant il n'y a pas des fusillades il
n'y a pas eu de coups
un million d'armes aux états unis il n'y
a pas une augmentation drastique depuis
2000 des automutilations et des suicides
est ce que la société américaine n'est
pas profondément malade et est ce que
ces métastases ne sont pas en train
d'irradier l'intégralité de la planète
quand on entend george bush dire le
train de vie des américains n'est pas
négociable est ce que vous ne pensez pas
qu'il y ait une remise en question
conduite introspective kiné
les américains ne sont plus capables de
faire parce que ils s'estiment les
maîtres du monde
chaque année ce sera de plus en peut
voler l'europe à l'ouest à l'occident
c'est un concept extrêmement profond sur
le plan stratégique à prendre en cause
c'est pas une question de pouvoir dur
mais c'est une question de d'occasion
d'opportunités pour l'instant
parce que le système politique chinois
est tellement répressif c'est pas eu
lieu on peut faire des affaires c'est
très difficile mais à long terme au
21ème siècle une stratégie sur le siècle
si on considère la fin du siècle quelle
sera la nation qui sera
le but qui ont le plus de succès faut
répondre à cette question à quoi le
succès
capacité d'être
maintenir le système opérationnel du
monde ou est ce que les chinois veulent
tour au câble et parce que ça va
tenir à la suprématie du dollar contrôle
et l'innovation
il pourrait y avoir des révolutions
dans l'impression 3d sur la façon dont
on produit des choses
un réveil aussi de l'industrie on
pourrait devenir moins dépendants du
pétrole parce qu'on peut être l'énergie
de la fusion aussi avec le solaire et
hydraulique mais bon je vais peut-être
un peu vieux jeu en disant ça mais en
pensant à l'avenir il faut toujours se
souvenir du passé c'est véritablement
une des bases
sur la façon de voir ce qui vient sur
une passe plus longue
vous savez on réfléchit à la décennie 10
20 ans mais quand on réfléchit à 2060
l'espace
l'espace proche mais regardons les
modèles des mouvements sur des périodes
plus longues 200 300 ans sur la période
du commerce maritime etc
les etats unis sont restés aussi
important qu'il l'était même si eu
quelques petits changements à la marge
rv nous interrogent les intérêts vitaux
des états unis quels sont pour vous les
trois principaux intérêts vitaux des
états unis
frustré je dirais qu aux bac tu dois
dire revient l'idée d'être un endroit où
on peut faire les choses
où les gens veulent venir et être
heureux
ce bon c'est créer un endroit sûr sur le
plan de vue de la sécurité
le cyber espace
[Musique]
pour être véritablement que les gens
soient libres
envoyer des navires à travers l'océan
sans avoir une crainte c'est un jeu que
les chinois ne veulent pas jouer parce
que ce serait trop chère pour
peut-être le troisième intérêts
le maintien des relations qu'ils ont
tellement servi entre les états unis et
l'europe et leurs alliés il ya une autre
façon de penser à ça c est ce qu on peut
faire de nouveaux amis
parce que quand il est tellement de
turbulences dans certains pays
certains pays peuvent sortir d'autres
orbite mais l'idée c'est que si
l'amérique
veut doit être le lieu où on veut aller
c'est que il faut rester engagés dans le
monde à notre niveau pour que les gens
viennent nous rejoindre c'est une
question véritablement de confiance pour
répondre à une de vos questions sur
l'irak
il faut que ce soit au niveau des
dirigeants aussi au niveau de la rue et
ça c'est quand je pense à avec à
l'avenir est ce que un pays comme les
etats unis peuvent
attirer des gens à l'avenir oui
c'est un récit c'est très très important
dans les relations internationales et
quand on est dans un monde de plus en
plus virtuel
l'idée c'est que
c'est là est-ce qu'on est plus attractif
est ce qu'on est toujours aussi
attractif quels sont les trois intérêts
les trois principaux intérêts vitaux des
européens
parce qu'un mec est choquée bah quoi
sans café j'allais faire des blagues au
sujet du croissant du café non
je fais des frites
que c'était des freedom fries les frites
de la liberté c'est ça prendre le
contrôle de la dialectique à
l'américaine c'est renommer les frites
ouais
d'un point de vue européen
si l'amérique est un pays neuf
vous savez l'union européenne c'est une
expérience très récente prenez en compte
une idée d' éviter quand j'ai vécu en
france les années 90
lorsque l'union européenne émerger c'est
très intéressant d'écouter les français
à en parler l'arrivée de l'europe que
faire de l'allemagne au 21ème siècle par
exemple une europe pacifique où l'union
européenne est viable permet une
intégration économique
je suis pas quelqu'un qui croit que
l'intégration économique est quelque
chose que on pourra conserver pour
toujours parce que vous avez deux
guerres mondiales au 20e siècle mais ça
vous donne une meilleure chance d'éviter
les conflits mondiaux dans les conflits
européens en tout cas
explique que l'expérience européenne
c'est important qu'elle continue c'est
important
j'en ai pas parlé jusqu'à présent l'idée
de
réchauffement climatique
imaginez l'économie
énergétique
les européens sont mieux partis que les
américains là dessus
le troisième point ce serait
du fait de la transformation sociale
je dois parler du livre que j'ai écrit
mais on est dans un moment où les
populations
ont de moins en moins d'occasions
économique
il ya un niveau de vie très très haut
dans le contrat social en europe
beaucoup plus qu'aux états unis ce que
les gens attendent en tant de soins
sociaux de revenus
soins de santé ce sera un problème très
très durs particulièrement pour l'europe
avec beaucoup de nations parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui s'est investi
là-dedans ça sera sur le plan économique
de plus en plus difficile de remplir ses
obligations la et d implication dans
tous
les dépenses de défense
si vous regardez
un budget comme un jeu à somme nulle
serre que vous prenez de l'argent
quelque part pour payer pour autre chose
vous allez payer pourquoi pour un
salaire minimum ou est-ce que vous allez
payer pour avoir plus d'avions de chasse
c'est très difficile à concilier un mois
ça me fascine comme question
une petite fiction que j'ai écrite ça
c'était intéressant et réfléchir même du
point de vue français quels sont les
choix est-ce que la france par exemple
peut conserver une armée
d'être réglée des humains
dans les années 2040 ou coup la plupart
des armées ont automatisé numériser
leurs floral rose leur armée
par exemple mettre ses forces dans un
dans un bunker et d'utiliser les forces
humaines que lorsqu'on a besoin et c'est
très intéressant d'un point de vue
futuriste
c'est une notion très importante sur la
façon de gérer cette question là quels
sont les trois intérêts et les trois
principaux intérêts vitaux de la chine
je pense avec la chine c'est que si vous
êtes du point de vue de she's in fine
vous bénéficiez du parti communiste
comment maintenir le pays unis comme
s'écroule pas
quelque chose qui soit cohérent un
système politique cohérent politique
cohérent c'est très très difficile à
faire là bas
l'hétérogénéité dans l'économie dans la
culture dans cette société en étant
donnée son échelle est quelque chose qui
est sans précédent dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
surtout avec cette clash de la modernité
une phrase washington
quels sont les facteurs plus importante
d'une situation pour essayer de
comprendre un politique de politiques
étroits politique
la chine c'est un peu comme ça qu'est ce
que numéro un c'est éviter que le pays
s'écroule en petits morceaux de
maintenir le pays pour qu'ils
s'écroulent pas numéro 3 maintenir le
pays ensemble
pour avoir une réponse plus spécifique
sur le numéro de numéro trois c'est le
changement démographique dans cette
société qui se produit en même temps que
ce genre je mens économique c'est à dire
que on a véritablement une courbe de
gauss avec des gens de plus en plus âgés
même si l'économie est en croissance les
les coût de la vie augmente et
vous voyez qu'on délocalise beaucoup de
choses de la chine vers le vietnam vers
d'autres pays où le coût de la vie est
moins chère
et comme en europe ce troisième point
sur équilibré cette notion de comment
maintenir une telle population au
travail nourri
qu'ils se sentent vraiment réussir avec
tellement de contradictions et c'est
quelque chose de très très cher en
réaliser
j'essaie de réfléchir
quelles sont les choses qui pourraient
arrêter la croissance militaire chinoise
ça à voir avec ça
les trois intérêts vitaux de la russie
maintenant
à celle là l'est du recel et stéphanie à
des casa qui s'exilent pour moi parce
que je le vois à travers la perspective
de quelqu'un comme poutine donc c'est
tout ce que je peux répondre aussi n'ont
jamais j'avais est ce que c'est possible
de faire une prospective sur un pays
sans jamais y avoir mis les pieds
bonne question c'est beaucoup plus dur
bien sûr
préciser ma question sans y avoir mis
les pieds et
cissé sur place si les gens sont sur
place s'ils ne sortent pas de ces petits
cercles d'expatriés qui pue lui comme de
la vermine dans les salons feutrés des
ambassades
lui a dit m fashion
expatriés professionnel ça pourrait être
n'importe quoi c'est possible de mon
point de vue
j'étais avec
l'ambassadeur de russie dans un jeu de
escape game quand j'avais 10 12 ans j'ai
étudié le russe
avec un tuteur avec un prof
malades y était
je parle un petit peu le russe mais pas
voulu tout un tout petit peu vous
connaissez comme gros mot en russe
vous connaissez des gros mots en russe
non
pas du tout non non vous connaissez avec
deux ans
vous en moi je connaissais que toutes
les insultes aux états unis j'ai pris
part
est-ce que vous pouvez connaître un pays
sans connaître la base de la langue là
ce qui anime un peuple ont dit que l'
architecture d'une langue détermine
larchitecture de la pensée en france en
français par d'où on a besoin de 30 %
mots en plus par rapport aux états unis
hier ça nous ça nous gêne dans le
business parce qu'ils n'ont pas la brr
d'accord les agenais et le monde
anglophone et spécialement le
commonwealth n'a pas ce problème là
parce que j'utilise 30% mo mois en russe
vous avez la capacité en une seule
phrase de dire 13 sens de mots
qu'est ce que vous en pensez qu est-ce
qu on peut connaître un pays un peuple
comme aux états unis pareil si vous ne
connaissez pas les petites ramifications
d'une langue
c'était difficile à comprendre la
culture profondément sans avoir une
expérience de la langue
je crois que c'est très dur
en tant que quelqu'un qui tente
d'utiliser la fiction et l'imagination
je n'ai pas simplement d'autres cultures
d'autres situations d'autres d'autres
emplois mais comprendre le futur aussi
si vous voulez comprendre ce que vous ne
connaissez pas c'est un petit peu ce que
je disais précédemment
ça vous évite cet écueil mais
une des expériences comme on a eu c'est
pas un secret mais c'est un aspect de la
photo photo moi je suis jamais allé à
hawaï mais on a écrit des choses
extraordinaires sur hawaï sans spoiler
votre livre donner un petit apéritif à
nos lecteurs sur quel est le début de
conflit comment ça s'est passé comment
ça se passe quel type de technologie sur
place quel type de réaction
dans la flotte fantôme pour les ir
l'histoire commence en fait avec une
découverte en énergie la chine
un tournant en avant et après et ils
peuvent avoir une indépendance
énergétique
et la façon la plus extraordinaire c'est
comment la troisième guerre mondiale
débute cette question est-ce que ça
commence avec
un missile qui passe par dessus le pôle
nord est ce que c'est un sous marin ou
quelque chose de ce genre là qui qui qui
fait couler un bateau dont on se pose la
question
il faudra powe et peut-être sur infos
persos d'un faux pavillon ça peut
commencer comme ça aussi
ça commence avec la guerre dans l'espace
du point de vue américain d'un
astronaute américain sur une station
internationale
qui est mis dehors par
ses camarades
russe à l'intérieur de la station
spatiale et on passe rapidement vers
hawaii parce que bon allez je fais un
petit peu de divulguer chez
parce que c'est une question est ce que
ça pourrait vraiment c'est arrivé
c'est pas la façon dont vers
l'afghanistan 79 les chinois utilisent
des cartes bourlhonne roelofs des cargos
des porte conteneurs
tout d'abord c'est des petits et suivez
chênois puis après il ya des chars etc
et c'est une tromperie comment comment
est-ce qu'on peut cacher les choses
comment est ce que peut cacher une
invasion
c'est bien sûr on commence à y réfléchir
avec l'ukraine comment est-ce qu'on
mobilise une force d'invasion
six militaires
ça c'est l'ancienne façon de faire c'est
efficace hein mais les russes l'ont fait
l'otan aussi
axial mais les exercices
de l'otan
ça signifie pas de traverser et d'aller
en russie
l'opération s'est montrée fiable
c'est tout est une question de
vocabulaire que ce soit chez les russes
ou les américains
non mais avait des objectifs aussi là
il ya si vous voulez l'aspiration à dire
que vous éviterez que les choses se font
ça en vous engageant dans des manoeuvres
très complexe avec des dizaines de
milliers de soldats plusieurs nations
je ne pense pas que les exercices
militaires
soit une façon d'éviter ce genre
d'action mais bon c'est une autre
conversation
comment est ce que l'on comprend
l'environnement sans avoir été sur place
critique du en eau douce chara design
est mon monde qu écrivain là mon
collègue était hawaï un peu mais il
était très content de la façon dont on a
décrit hawaï d'un point de vue pratique
voyons ils l'ont bien reçu ça c'est à
passer le cap
maintenant ça nous a évité beaucoup de
de pression
en fait on ne devrait pas beaucoup de
choix parce que c'était un
très grand moment on s'est rendu compte
que sur le plan créatif on prend un
risque et ça peut payer mais ça peut
aussi échoué et c'est l'idée de
crédibilité
tout comme on essaie de comprendre
le langage comme un civil qui écrit en
langage militaire il est vital de
comprendre comment les écrivent c'est
pas seulement l'utilisation d'acronymes
mais si vous êtes dans un bar par
exemple
les gens
qui rentrent de
d'une mission il parle avec beaucoup
d'acronymes et pour quelqu'un qui est
extérieur à ça il comprend pas très bien
m capable de mieux comprendre comment
communiquer avec les gens du monde
militaire qui sont vos lecteurs et
comment on peut les amener à croire
l'histoire que vous écrivez
principalement ci s'est mis dans quelque
part dans l'avenir
pour repousser les limites parce que
peuvent croire que c'est pas possible
mais il est vital d'essayer de
comprendre et de d'entrer dans ce genre
de langage c'est pas simplement que le
personnage est le bon dialogue non mais
comprendre de façon anthropologique ce
qui est important pour eux comment par
exemple quelle est leur lien avec leur
famille
comment est-ce qui parle aux gens qui
sont à l'extérieur de leur cercle c'est
important quand on fait une craie quand
on crée un monde par exemple ce qu'ils
votent peut-être
ses aspects
[Musique]
j'y pense aussi une autre manière
c'est simplement l'effet des détails
sont importants mais
bien comprendre donner aux lecteurs
suffisamment pour qu'il puisse se faire
un film veut même mais leur permettre
aussi
que j'aimerais bien apprendre un petit
peu parce que rien de pire en fait que
rien de pire que lire quelque chose
et où vous sentez qu'on vous donne une
leçon on vous donne une conférence et
que vous perdiez la capacité de vous
mettre dans dans la peau de quelqu'un
c'est moi c'est comme si je regardais un
film c'est comme ça que mon cerveau
fonctionne en tant qu'écrivain en
écrivant des thrillers des techno
thriller où il ya beaucoup d'action
on parle d'avions de chasse de sous
marins etc
c'est important pour moi de voir la
scène
d'être au milieu de la sède de divers
points de vue et ça vous permet
véritablement de comprendre
comme si vous racontez quelqu'un ce qui
se passait
d'un point de vue analytique et des
perspectives c'est d'une façon
de dépasser le lac rom de l'écrivain
c'est de dire bah voilà qu'est ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est un point
fondamental
décidé de pouvoir y rentrer avec leurs
propres idées on va parler un peu de
cuisine
et
l'intelligence artificielle les robes ou
avec capacité de prise de décision
l'étal les capacités que les militaires
des legs ou au complexe militaro
industriel
les drones les drones autonome que ce
soit dans les airs ou sous la mer ou les
chiens patrouilleurs
comment vous voyez l'avenir en termes de
technologie et les répercussions que ça
va pouvoir avoir sur les populations
civiles
qui analyse le code de l'intelligence
artificielle est ce qu'il n'ya pas des
billets de programmation
qui comment vous voyez l'avenir sur les
questions d
une des façons dont je le vois
qu'est ce que c'est que de vivre dans un
monde dans une telle technologie que ce
soit des chiens de police d'aider des
robots comment est ce que moi je me
comportais qu'est-ce que ça va changer
comment est ce que je vais penser
comment ce que je vais réfléchir
l'idée d' auto-censure dans certains
régimes que les gens développent
naturellement qu'est ce qu'on peut
entrer dans un domaine où il y aura une
surveillance globale où tout de la
montrer aux portes et la voiture vous
utilisez le restaurant que vous utilisez
où vous allez manger la carte de crédit
que vous utilisez pas tout tout est déjà
listés on s'est tous un point où ça
ça va décoller comme ça et la question
c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer après
quand je pense à la y ait ce monde
robotisée c'est qu'elle est le monde
dans lequel je voudrais vivre
et regarde en arrière
et si je le décompose un petit peu
réfléchir à la capacité
de ne pas se sentir
humainement d'être constamment
surveiller parce que c'est vraiment
stressant que c'est une expérience
terrible à avoir mais on y est déjà
et
c'est un peu comme être parano
je dirais pas ça correctement mais bidc
c'est pas parce que vous êtes parano qui
a pas quelqu'un qui vous suit dans la
rue
et entre nos iphone nos cartes de crédit
le montant de données utilisées
et l'agent la lie en fait c'est
détermine de votre existence tout les
planifier c'est bien ça altère les
relations qu'on a entre nous entre êtres
humains ce qui est encore plus
inquiétant c'est que est ce qu'on se
rend compte c'est des gens qui
continuent à regarder des applications
qui vont sur l'euro
est une des choses terribles ce sujet
c'est que la chose la technologie la
plus efficace c'est qu'elle était
invisible on n'aperçoit pas c'est
vraiment un dd des défis le plus
extraordinaire avec l'ail
l'intelligence artificielle par doumbia
mais par exemple que c'est que quelqu'un
va avoir une décision qui a été prise
sur une demande de crédit qu'elle est
prise par l'ia ces décisions sont prises
sur l'intelligence artificielle
ça ne quittera jamais parce que elle n'a
pas le bon profil et si on n'a pas cette
compréhension au niveau de la société
comment toutes ces choses là fonctionne
c'est une question d'éducation prenant
que deux politiques prenons un cas
concret
le droit à l'avortement aux états unis
quand certains états sont capables de
poursuivre en justice certaines femmes
qui ont avorté et certains états
utilisent leur historique de recherche
leur livre consulter les choses qu'elles
ont pu commander vous avez entendu
parler de cette histoire
c'est c'est qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est mettre en danger les
femmes c'est à dire les obliger à encore
avortée avec des aiguilles à tricoter
c'est le puritanisme américain qui se
remet à nice est parce qu il a peur
qu'est-ce que sexe est ce que la
violation de la vie privée
comptes seront des cantons ce ne se
rendait pas compte réellement ce que par
exemple histoire de l'avortement et des
gens un peu produits du moins c'est que
cet été
sera très lourd aux états unis
ce que la cour suprême va probablement
là permettre à certains états de
d'établir des lois anti-avortement
cette question sur la vie privée de
façon extrêmement concrète c'est pas une
question abstraite
quand quelqu'un a une appelation à une
application qui suit son rythme
cardiaque par exemple et puis soudain il
ya
par exemple
vous aurez des données qui montreront
que une femme est sur le point d'avoir
un avortement et que ça pourrait être
utilisé contre elle
et
on a aucun débat intéressant là dessus
c'était trop tard trop tard pour avoir
cette conversation il ya un risque
on aura probablement cette conversation
très prochainement mais mais quand vous
regardez la façon dont les lois sont
faites aux états unis comment elles sont
votées les mouvements qui sont
nécessaires au niveau politique pour
changer quelques choses aussi basiques
les droits sur les données ce qui n'est
pas une donnée ce qui part à une
conversation importantes aux états unis
pour l'instant mais c'est vital
ça va exiger et c'est un des aspects de
ce qui se passe avec
le renversement de de la loi sur
l'avortement aux états unis
mais d'un point de vue politique d'un
point de vue des entreprises aussi
québec lé l'obligation morale de la
technologie dans ce domaine et on a eu
aucun débat public là-dessus aux états
unis et on doit en avoir
causé du mal
la capacité de causer du mal
des électrons il ya des myriades de
façon de le faire un des algorithmes
plus spécifiquement dans les réseaux
sociaux
comment est ce qu'on est militant pour
nous mêmes alors que les hommes
politiques s'en fiche un des politiciens
s'en fiche c'est pas simplement de la
militance mais aussi du déterminisme
je veux dire que je suis un optimiste
qui regarde dans l'abyme je crois aux
possibilités humaines au potentiel mais
j'ai beaucoup de nuits
insomniaques au sujet de ce qui peut se
produire à l'avenir et c'est une des
périodes qui est très très dur à y
réfléchir tenter d'arriver avec quelque
chose qui ne me fasse
pas rentrer dans un vraiment dans une
année extrêmement noir et déprimante
si je veux être jouable de l'espoir
le changement vient parfois
d'une alternative
de côté
peut-être qu'un débat des gens dans la
rue un débat sur l'avortement
pourrait
s'occuper de cette question des données
et de la vie privée parce que ça
tellement d'importance sur la sécurité
aux états unis quel regard vous portez
sur la nsa quel regard vous portez sur
la sphère snowdon quel regard vous
portez sur le fait que là est née sa
récolte - saône depuis des années des
datas partout dans le monde qu'elle a
stocké pendant des années
quel maintenant grâce à des capacités de
calcul elle peut traiter qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la sphère snowdon
highlights ne faire garder la force
noden
c'est comme une des opérations de
renseignement les plus extraordinaires
mené par la russie qu'on ait jamais vu
j'ai bien compris vous m'aviez dit quoi
quand je la vois aussi des recettes
révélations faites d'art edward snowden
par le vol de données
le dossier et qu'il termine qui se
retrouvent à moscou en passant de hong
kong pour moi
c'est mon sentiment
c'est ma vision
conspirationnistes mon état d'esprit
d'espions c'est comme une opération
moi je n'aurais jamais pu inventer sa en
tant qu'écrivain
ces bons instincts des copains
programmeurs
non j'ai beaucoup de copains
programmeurs et vous discutez avec eux
ils sont aux premières lignes des
algorithmes ils sont en première ligne
la majeure partie des programmeurs que
nous on connaît vous ne veulent plus
travailler à ça ils ne sont pas recrutés
par des services extérieurs
c'est une des grandes tensions depuis la
sphère stand n qu'est ce qu'est la
silicon valley passablement ciconne
valley en californie mais quelle est la
relation des gens avec la nsa avec nos
gouvernements en général parce que d'un
côté
il ya un désir de rejeter
un petit nombre de gens disent il faut
travailler sur les problèmes de sécurité
nationale mais au niveau des claviers il
ya un antagonisme très fort mais c'est
la question de confiance encore une fois
mais quand on me demande ce que je pense
sur la situation de snow des gels et
j'ai les cheveux qui se dressent sur la
tête parce que la logique interne n'a
aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens pour moi
c'est une opération de renseignement
est-ce que c'est territoriale je sais
pas qu'est ce que c'est
conspirationnisme je sais quand vous
voyez que votre constitution
écrite par les pères fondateurs et
dévoyé par votre armée
you baudouy son lac
lac chelsea manning lax node
on tire larmes
est ce que les américains
est ce que les américains irs la larme
est ce que les américains n'ont pas
oublié les valeurs des pères fondateurs
n'ont besoin d'un an lorsque c'est un
des grands débats aux états unis les
valeurs fondamentales l'idée de liberté
mais
comment est-ce qu'on tire larmes c'est
important
dans le travail trop avec les militaires
vous parlez comme un militaire
quand j'entends quand je vous entends
parler c'est à dire mettre ça sur le
point d'une opération russe grâce à ce
modèle nous fait pourquoi il a terminé
en russie ce nous donne parce que
c'était le seul état qui était capable
d'assurer sa sécurité contre les
kidnappings et les tentatives
d'assassinât de la cia
mais nous on voudrait bien l'accueillir
en france comme comme julian assange
mais comme votre pays fait des
opérations chez nous à longueur de
journée
on peut pas assurer leur sécurité parce
que on est trop mauvais face à vous
mais si vous fait fuiter des documents
avec l'idée de s'appliquer ça la liberté
avec des valeurs qui de point de vue
comme vous dites sont constitutionnels
commencez vous pouvez décider d'aller un
lieu où vous ne pouvez pas dire ce que
vous voulez
un endroit comme la russie mais vous
pouvez cette question de sécurité
physique moi ça je prends un cas concret
je prends un cas concret vous êtes dans
un service de renseignement et vous
voyez par exemple l'opération stellar
wind connaissez l'opération c'était la
wind c'est quoi l'opération stellar wind
sur vence de la surveillance d'haïti
enti en fait des services et étendez
votre réponse n'est pas complète
qui est ce qu'il ya derrière
c'est la nsa mais qu'est ce que la une
et c'est surveillé des citoyens les
citoyens américains ça c'est la vraie
répondants sont utilisés les télécoms
américaine
pour capturer les dacquois ce qui est
interdit ce qui était interdit ou ce
qu'ils ont fait ici
vous êtes dans cette société et vous
allez voir votre
supérieur hiérarchique et vous lui dites
vous avez pas quoi on est en train de
pomper et donner notre propre pays sur
notre propre concitoyens et moi j'ai
appris à l'école que dans la
constitution on n'a pas le droit de le
faire
qu'est ce que vous croyez que voie de l
+ 1 va faire il va vous écouter il va
appeler la police on va dire tu te tais
parce que sinon tu perds ton travail
ce qui va te dire tu te tais sinon
j'appelle le fbi l'ail et je vais est
accusé avec ce nouveau mac carthysme néo
mccarthysme je vais est accusé de
trahison
est ce que vous pensez pas que c'est
plus patriotes que d'être obligé d'aller
se réfugier chez les russes parce que
votre propre état est devenu sourd et
aveugle non
non je pense pas
ouais
la façon dont je suis penserait c'est
d'aller voir des législateurs au congrès
général comme ça
des gens qui travaillent sur les
commissions de renseignement et si vous
voulez torpiller des secrets nationaux
oui parce que il ya ya ya ya un coup
dans le lancer la larme
mais moi j'arrive pas à me faire aller
dans un pays comme la russie l'allemagne
bon
allez voir un membre du coin devrait
être avec une commission pour moi la
logique interne et plus plus clair le
résultat serait le même ce que si vous
lâchez l'information mais de trouver
refuge dans la russie de poutine non moi
j'y arrive pas j'arrive pas à jarry
paris me faire
puisque vous êtes américains pour ça
revenons revenu au data et
quand on voit quand on voit à l'heure
actuelle que new data sont siphonnées et
que nous sommes tout nu comprenez
l'expression tout nu tenir le rôle mais
kate ils feront tu en fasses delà des
business des corporations des services
de renseignement que ce soit le vôtre le
nôtre le mossad le gru le fsb et je vous
en passe et des meilleures nous en tant
que société civile que doit-on faire ce
- prospectiviste
j'ai bien
regardé le secteur privé et le secteur
public et voir où est ce qu'on peut
progresser le plus rapidement
je voudrais penser que en parallèle on
peut
du côté commercial
la véritable propriété de vos données
arriver à cela dans dix quinze ans
d'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on aura moins d'heures de travail
à faire
quand on vendra nous donner ou que nos
données sont vendus pour des
publicitaires en tirer d'en tirer un
bénéfice est ce que c'est une idée à
poursuivre pour pouvoir gagner sa vie
ça pourrait résoudre la question mais du
côté gouvernemental
les niveaux de
2,2 cryptogamiques plutôt graphie de
cryptographie
avec
les ordinateurs quantiques c'est
fascinant parce qu'il ya deux façon dont
ça peut aller
par exemple quand je fais cette
projection l'individu face les tel état
il ya la capacité de craquer n'importe
quel secret
ça sera totalement déstabilisant que
jack canon
pourquoi vous soulevez les sourcils mais
il faut nous donner de l'information
concrète est ce que les états unis ont
déjà la capacité de briser tous les mots
de passe comme les chinois peuvent le
faire
alors tu ne sais pas je ne sais pas
je pense que les services de
renseignements de tous pays tentent de
casser les codes mais bon je ne sais pas
du côté quantique en utilisant mon
esprit futuriste
il ya l'idée que
toutes les données que les chinois ont
volé pourront être utilisés bien sûr
c'est un très grande très grande menace
ce qu'avait clients on peut modéliser
une société
qu'on peut manipuler je vous coupe
quelle est la différence pour nous
français que ce soit les chinois qui
nous volent nous donner où que ce soit
les américains qui nous voulons nous
donner
me dit pas
les etats unis c'est de la m d'intel
free
et puis parce que sinon je vous fais la
petite musique derrière avec les violons
des flûtes d'accord donc quelle est la
différence pour un français de se faire
avoir par les chinois ou de se faire
avoir par les américains parce que je
veux bien les chinois torture les
ouigours stérilise les femmes oui d'où
on our fonds du crédit social mange des
enfants ce que vous voulez mais les
états unis torture menthe
envoie des armes à uranium appauvri en
irak par tout ça donne des enfants avec
des cancers ils nous ont même nous
français bombardé du lsd en 1960 à l'eau
quelle est la différence pour nous entre
les états unis la chine
l'attention du gouvernement finalement
je sais que plusieurs de ses semblables
si les français de volée mais donnait
aussi les chinois
un certain niveau c'est pas de
différence parce que vous perdez la
possession de vos informations mais je
serai moins inquiet
si c'était les français plutôt que les
chinois
l'objectif stratégique est différent
l'utilisation la militarisation de des
données volées que ce soit une
modélisation de l'europe que ce soit les
les courriels pour envoyer des ddd
courrier spécialisés ou alors pour le
faire pendant tant de guerre moi moi ça
m'inquiéterait moins que ce soit les
français qui le fasse plutôt que les
russes ou les chinois le contexte
signifie beaucoup pour moi
et c'est pas
c'est pas pour me voiler la face
regardez où on en est aujourd'hui
regardez où on sera à l'avenir moi n'y a
pas d'équivalence entre les deux mêmes
mais même dans ce cas là vous parlez une
militarisation des données
militarisation de la pensée donc c'est à
dire que je prends un exemple imaginez
vous que vous réalisiez quelqu'un qui
ressemble à donald trump mais sous
stéroïdes bien
bien bien costaud bien énervé il a en sa
possession des lames de rasoir pour
faire chanter des juges chanter comment
il s'appelait votre américain président
qui est partie le watergate des
commentateurs ex à richard nixon est ce
que vous pensez pas que vous êtes et
vous pensez pas qu'on est en train ou
vote lobby militaro industriel ou votre
lobby de la silicon valley est en train
ou votre lobby de la nsa est en train de
donner des lames de rasoir à des singes
[Musique]
c'est à dire si je compensais religion
tu parler lentement si vous préférez
je comprends les deux ordis tour tous
ces outils
que la communauté du renseignement
ou les militaires en tassant blé
pourrait facilement être utilisé dans
des mains d'un méchant président d'un
mauvais président contre ses propres
citoyens
comme dans un régime autoritaire comme
la chine par exemple
c'est quelque chose qui m'inquiéterait
beaucoup ça vous inquiète ou pas la
façon d outil extrêmement puissant
et on a eu une présidence extrêmement
inquiétante qui peut il peut se
présenter à nouveau et de gagner à
nouveau
donc cette question à nouveau de s'être
capables de prendre en compte le rôle de
l'individu dans la société
et par exemple c'est rod higgins tweed
c'est dans ce qu'on disait précédemment
sur la loi sur l'avortement
c'est en 2024 il y aura une nouvelle
élection
chaque citoyen occidental que ce soit en
france que ce soit en allemagne
pour autant que ça compte doit avoir à
l'esprit
à quoi utilisons-nous la technologie
actuellement ça pourrait toujours être
utilisé dans un mauvais escient est
vraiment un coup de commutateurs et ça
peut venir contre vous donc au niveau
constitutionnel au niveau des lois c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas abstrait
n'est plus abstrait c'est quelque chose
de très réel très concret et essayer de
trouver des voies pour que les gens en
soient conscients c'est important parce
qu'il ya tellement de choses complexes
dans ces questions montrez-moi votre
livre
magnifique est ce qu'on peut parler de
simple plus en détails je vous écoute
pourquoi avoir écrit ce bouquin l'un
à nos réponses que j'ai donnée est
évidente l'idée que nous vivons dans une
société où dans des sociétés où on
connaît tous de nous est en fait rien et
qu' on n'a plus de voix on n'a plus de
voix au chapitre
en amérique à 15 ans d'aujourd'hui
où beaucoup moins d'américains auront un
travail intéressant
il y aura plus de résistance
du côté de l'extrême droite par des
politiciens mais aussi par des gens qui
sont intéressés au sens anarchique du
terme de créer le chaos je dis rien je
dis rien sur les rues saint de ce
côté-là rien du russe le temps c'est un
problème interne intérieur l'idée qu' on
peut se retrouver dans un monde
où
tout ce qui était important à vos yeux
ne l'est plus parce qu'un changement de
modèle économique culture etc c'est ce
qui nous a motivé à écrire ce livre
contrôle
on passe dans un domaine où lee a et la
robotique transforme tous les aspects de
la société ça va transformer les choses
fondamentales qui nous donne notre
identité quelles sont nos emplois notre
travail
ça va changer la façon dont les
politiques sont capables de
nous envoyer de nos des messages mais de
contrôler aussi les populations
avec des mêmes technologies
personne ne veut en parler
c'est pas une discussion au goût du jour
c'est quelque chose de très déprimant
c'est une façon de penser déprimante
et puis quand on a fini de bouquins on
s'est regardés on a dit
que jésus on essaie de faire comprendre
aux gens des choses qu'on veut éviter la
flotte fantôme c'était ça aussi
il faut comprendre comprendre
l'impensable
ce qu'on peut ne pas voir du monde
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'on veut pas le
voir on veux pas le regarder et pour moi
faire des romans là dessus c'est une
façon de rendre les gens conscients
on peut être diverti y avoir cette
conscience c'est important de pouvoir le
faire d'une façon qui est accessible à
tout le monde tout le monde peut lire un
bouquin vous ai même pas besoin de
l'acheter 1 vous avez dans une
bibliothèque
l'espoir c'est quand qu'on prononce ces
questions autrement complexe sur la
technologie d'un point de vue humain
il ya une histoire d'un agent d'une
agente de la hesbaye avec sa famille
aussi mais aussi qui doit se battre
contre un adversaire terroriste qui a le
pouvoir sur certains robots mais aussi
sa relation avec son époux
que sa fille et son épouse
c'est un type qui est allé dans les
grandes écoles américaines c'est un
avocat n'a jamais rien fait de mal dans
sa vie un bon garçon un bon gars
c'est quelqu'un qui croit que le système
américain du doigt quelque chose et en
raison d'un algorithme dans sa firme de
deux avocats et bien son job qui lui
payait une somme fabuleuse et bien il
n'a plus beaucoup d'applications pour
notre héroïne parce que c'est pas
simplement quelqu'un qui devient la
seule personne qui rapporte le pain à la
maison mais aussi la nature de ce
qu'elle a fait pour sauver washington y
compris travailler avec un robot que son
mari méprisé lui qui est en train de la
haïr parce que elle travaille avec un
robot qui lui a piqué son boulot et
c'est fascinant c'est une expérience
humaine c'est vraiment une histoire
totalement différente de la flotte
fantôme pour ces raisons là c'est
beaucoup sur le fait d'entrer dans la
tête des gens qui vivent dans cette
amérique de l'avenir
sur les data sur le fait que la machine
va nous remplacer
on va complètement changer de sujet
l'espace d'un instant est ce que vous
attendez à des émeutes aux états unis à
cause de la condition sociale qui se
dégrade est-ce que vous pensez que votre
démocratie est en danger car votre
système est pourri qu'il met trop de
gens dans la précarité
et que l'humain n'est peut-être pas fait
pour vivre avec deux american way of
life
et lacroix riz l'inégalité un problème
structurel aux états unis ça pourrait
vraiment détruire le pays dans les 20 30
années à venir
notre incapacité d'éduquer les jeunes de
s'occuper de nos malades
bon ça peut avoir l'air
pessimisme en avait très peu de progrès
pour relever ces problèmes ces questions
et défis de façon cohérente et on parle
même pas de la violence des armes
regardez simplement la l'éducation et
des soins et le la sécu quoi on a parlé
haut ces trois modèles si on veut être
l'endroit où on a les meilleurs qui
viennent pour travailler
j'y serai correct d'avoir un endroit où
on a les gens les plus les mieux éduqués
dans ce sens le plus large possible au
monde on ne peut pas délocaliser
l'invention
ou l'éducation il ya très peu d'intérêt
à le faire pour l'instant c'est vraiment
ça fait de la peine quelqu'un qui a des
enfants qui regardent l'avenir on se
pose la question est ce que le monde en
vaudra la peine est-ce que sapphire a
une chance de le faire sans même parler
du réchauffement climatique
donc une partie de l'écriture d'un tel
récit est passé deux ans à réfléchir à
cette dystopie
l'appartement dans lequel je suis ce que
je vois le garder je le perde bah c'est
vraiment en arriver à
mettre la main sur ces paradoxes ces
modèles
savoir ce qu'on doit faire mais personne
ne veut le faire
permettre des inégalités économiques au
cif forte aux états unis mais moi je
suis pas un socialo 1 et
90e socialist
capitaliste et puis tu es lycée veut
rien dire ni marcher marcher sa démarche
et son ministre et non
à diabo
de permettre à telle richesse d'advenir
ses bouquins de permettre
leader il ya
de la tête du national est cent fois
mille fois plus que n'importe qui moi
j'étais journaliste
j'avais des gens autour de moi je
couvrais des histoires avec les gens les
plus riches de la banque j'ai vu la
première bulle de l'économie et de
l'internet c'est qui a éclaté j'ai vu le
deuxième éclatement de la bulle dotcom
j'ai vu venir ces choses là
et on est toujours incapable de
comprendre comment est ce que notre
société soit plus résiliente et comme
quelqu'un qui s'est spécialisé dans la
défense qui travaille là dessus de façon
très sérieuse
je pense qu'on en fait pas assez
attention
aux questions les plus les plus soft
comme
dynamisme nationale pas simplement pour
le mettre en ordre de bataille
la puissance de l'ami du militaire mais
comment s'occuper de ceux qui sont les
plus vulnérables
il n'y a pas d'avenir sans ça
ça peut ça peut avoir l'air pessimiste
moi je suis un américain fier mais je
suis vraiment très très désolé de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
actuellement vous savez ce qu'on dit en
français
sur le passé et l'avenir
qui ne connaît pas son passé est
condamné à le revivre
ses partenaires revenons revenons à vos
livres vous m'avez dit que vous écriviez
des livres avec un récit avec une
histoire pour passionner alors les
militaires pour qu'ils puissent lire les
dangers parce que vous comprenez c'est
trop aride les rapports aux militaires
ils comprennent pas assez
et vous écrivait des livres pour que si
j'ai bien compris que la population
civile comprennent les dangers auxquels
était elle est exposée je vais essayer
de citer une phrase de tête de votre co
auteur qui est nous écrivons ces
livres-là pas pour anticiper le futur
mais pour le prévenir moi je vais vous
dire je vous pose une question vous avez
vu le film idiocracy
la question que je vous pose c'est qui
va être très dur est ce que les gens ne
sont pas devenus trop court
pour comprendre à quelle sauce ils vont
être mangés
c'est l'aspect éducation est-ce qu'on
est en un point où les gens ne
comprennent pas ce qui se passe ce qui
leur a été fait ce qui leur arrive
c'est de plus en plus facile pour les
dirigeants politiques de
s'appuyer sur l'inattention des gens et
sur leur manque d'imagination
c'est pas une question d'intelligence
comme
par exemple
des croissances du qi on voit la
militarisation des choses difficile à
dire mais c'est très destructeur
si les gens ne peuvent pas réfléchir de
façon critique
que ce soit une nouvelle politique qui
va
prendre le pas sur eux ou par exemple la
destruction de l'obamacare
c'était une façon extraordinaire pour la
plupart des américains qui n'a jamais pu
avoir accès aux soins de santé
et l'attaquent contre l'album aker
c'était les choses à plus destructrice
qui ait pu être faite aux etats unis une
des expériences les plus importantes au
cours de la pandémie parce qu'on parlait
du revenu fondamentale du revenu de base
dans un monde dont on travaille -
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour
avoir une vie qui ait du sens pour
pouvoir vivre au cours de la pandémie
aux états unis je crois que en france
aussi il ya eu un soutien gouvernemental
en liquide un de l'argent les gens ont
reçu de l'argent l'argent magique
et c'était un prototype de ce que
d'autres futurs pourraient être
mais le débat à ce sujet
regardant vers l'avenir c'est pour
régler les questions actuelles qu'il
faudrait se rendre compte si un revenu
de base minimum est possible en
observant ce qui s'est passé est ce que
c'est parce que ça valait la peine
d'avoir ces risques d'inflation est ce
que ça valait la peine d'avoir cette
dette qui monte qui augmente
c'est très difficile d'avoir ce débat au
niveau national
regardez
bien par câble suspense
j'essaie de l'aisne ne pas regarder j'ai
passé tester bakar journalistique avec
al hilal un écran de télé devant moi
j'en ai fait le plein
en fait ce n'est plus utile pour la
réflexion
twitter c'est une façon merveilleuse de
ceux reliés aux gens de savoir ce que
des gens qui n'auraient pas pu voir mais
trop souvent l'algorithme réduit ma
vision du monde trop souvent ma capacité
de me concentrer
de de voir les choses de moi quelque
chose de neuf de différent quand tout le
monde regarde d'un côté moi je voudrais
se garder de l'autre les médias sociaux
les réseaux sociaux détruit cette
capacité et un tel conflit d'intérêts là
dedans et l'avenir dont on parle d'en
contrôler c'est l'expression de ce
sentiment intérieur en tente de
comprendre pour chacun bénéfices
technologiques il ya un coot ya un prix
à payer on espère nous que les gens de
la silicon valley les gens de la
communauté
technologique puisse les lire le livre
pour comprendre les conséquences de leur
invention qui rendent les gens riches
avec les stock options et tout ça mais
peut-être c'est la mauvaise chose à
faire pour l'amérique je sais que vous
êtes attendus par des militaires
français
juste après notre interview donc on va
prendre notre temps
[Musique]
on leur passe le bonjour d'ailleurs
parce que je suis sûr qu'ils sont en
train de me regarder et ils ont créé red
team une cellule de prospective où ils
font venir des auteurs de science
fiction pour l'euro ouvrit les chakras
lors il aurait les aider à penser en
dehors de la boîte
votre armée fait ça depuis longtemps
la nôtre commence à se réveiller comme
d'habitude
vous avez un regard critique sur sa sur
le
la maladie du sommeil des armées qui se
réveille toujours trop tard qui demande
toujours beaucoup de pognon alors que
nous on essaye de les aider mais est ce
que réellement ils ont envie d'être
aidés est ce que la prospective
ne les
confonds prépa avec leur midi leur
incapacité est ce que le poids de leur
hiérarchie
sclérosé gangréné ne nuit pas tout
simplement aux expériences de pensée
où j'ai plus d'espoir parce que qu'aux
états unis on a au moins
un débat plus élaborés sur la façon de
développer
et faire progresser de nouvelles idées
la plupart des gens qui travaillent
aux etats-unis travaillent sur des
powerpoint 1 les officiels c'est une
façon très inefficace de créer des idées
vous pouvez trouver en ligne
ddd graphique qui ont franchement aucun
sens
combien d'heures pour être évité combien
d'argent pourrait être économisée si
on évitait les power point édition
sirène dans les ca des milieux
militaires mais ça c'est vraiment très
fascinant c'est par là s'occupent du
problème
en ce monde qui ait pas de créativité
dans les rangs militaires parce que
y en a énormément de la créativité dans
les rangs militaires
pollinisation est ce qu'ils sont écoutés
par leur hiérarchie non
et c'est ça le problème
des plus grandes inquiétudes
actuellement avec l'ia et la robotique
c'est le théâtre de l'innovation l'idée
qu' on peut jeter 10 20 millions de
dollars
sur un concept pour une petite
entreprise
cocher une case voilà faire une
présentation powerpoint alors on
investit dans l'ia même si aucune
intention de le déployer à la bonne
échelle
à travers les forces aussi importants
que les nôtres c'est un risque très
grave
si on a ce genre de choses sans vraiment
avoir l'intention de transformer que
transformer des grandes organisations
c'est tellement dur les gens qui
investissent leur carrière
pour former des cellules d'information
d'innovation ont des carrières plus
courtes
les gens qui veulent avoir des carrières
longues
n'ont pas autant d'occasions de sortir
d'un parcours
normalisée nous on a une expression aux
français pour décrire ça pas de couilles
pas d' embrouille
j'aime bien être optimiste mais j'ai
beaucoup de pessimisme en france aussi
un domaine je vois beaucoup plus de
déficit d'eau
qui vont devenir généraux même des
généraux de fraîche date
qui en dit capable
de parler de protéger des chances au
cours de leur carrière pour leur
permettre de progresser parce que c'est
parce que vous faites dans votre boulot
est-ce que vous devenez
un grand dirigeant mais c'est de former
les gens qui vous suivent
un des grands de test aujourd'hui c'est
la réforme du corps de la marine
les marines qui abandonne les charges
emmerin f
35c de l'hérésie
ça déstabilise profondément la politique
et c'est la chose la plus correcte à
faire que j'ai vu depuis longtemps
et c'est un processus qui a pris du
temps
commandant
s'exposent à des risques énormes pour le
camp des marines parce que
des
disques attendait mais vous nous
arracher nos griffes
vous rendez les marines subordonnée à
la marine
et on pourra plus être capable de lutter
de se battre contre la chine est pour
moi de mon point de vue c'est d'une
transformation bureaucratique plus
importante
avec cette racine d'une excellente idée
de revoir tous depuis le fusil des
marines jusqu'à la façon dont
les petits groupes de soldats sur le
terrain ces forces conventionnelles pas
des forces spéciales
peuvent avoir un impact stratégique
ça n'a jamais fait partie de la
conversation classique sur ce qu'il
fallait faire avec des forces terrestres
mais maintenant cette conversation se
produit et c'est de là que vient une
partie de mon optimisme
parce que le travail d'état major pour
affecter ces échanges de les présenter
de façon convaincante
le dialogue tribales qui doit se
produire entre communautés parce que les
gens abandonnent ce qu'ils tiennent pour
être le plus cher principalement
l'aviation c'est doit être fait cette
notion de transformation
de casser la bureaucratie de faire la
bonne chose
chose qu'il faut observer et si ça rate
si c'est repoussé eh bien ça sera
vraiment très très grave
et ça va vraiment
avoir un effet très négatif sur l'avenir
sur la façon dont on aura la prochaine
génération de l'armé aérienne et des
chars par exemple des blindés
militarisation de la robotique
militaires l'utilisation des logiciels
dans la guerre
c'est très très difficile pour les états
unise c'est que dans notre
notre relation industrielle il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas de dress
ya pas un représentant du congrès qui
soit le porte parole de cette communauté
la six mois je vais faire quelque chose
pour soutenir ce programme si on
construit par exemple un algorithme à
pittsburgh
ça devient pas partie prenante de
l'establishment militaire c'est le
système qu'on aux états unis
donc il faut
il faut avoir ça à l'esprit quand on
parle de la transformation
semblable à l'idée que la robotique va
permettre plus de militarisation
parce qu'on pourra plus acheter des
dédits des avions de 100 millions de
dollars pour par avion sarah des
applications extrêmement profonde sur la
façon dont
les lille les entreprises ne sont pas
équipés pour le monde tel qu'il est
les entreprises qui vont travailler avec
le complexe militaro-industriel ce sera
difficile pour elle de fonctionner parce
qu'elles sont tellement intégré mais ce
sera surtout si difficile pour la
population de comprendre qu'on achète
des avions à 100 millions de l'aacc
alors qu'aux états unis
l'insuline pour les diabétiques coutu
fortune
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que non on
va poser la question différemment
quels sont vos billets lecture quels
sont vos
caisses qui nuit à votre prisme de
lecture est ce que vous avez fait votre
propre conduite introspective concernant
vos capacités à analyser la situation
est-ce que vous monde est-ce que vous
manquez de ce cynisme froid que la
guerre vous apporte est-ce que vous avez
refusé de mettre un doigt de pied dans
la piscine du cynisme de la guerre ou
est ce que vous le masque est très bien
qu'elle souffre aux angles morts
concernant votre prisme de lecture
à
penser la question de
réfléchir sans réfléchir c'est difficile
nécessaire l'analyse apprendre ce que
c'est pas une façon passive à la façon
dont
j ai accès s'est trouvé des activités
physiques
moi je suis un grand cycliste à moi je
suis
libertine bike
faut pas réfléchir véritablement quand
vous êtes année d'éviter une branche
d'arbre mais je prends du temps pour
faire du vélo ces jeux je reçois des
idées que j'avais pas précédemment
c'est comme avec les les médias et les
réseaux sociaux on est bombardé par le
truc moi je regarde par exemple le
sticker là
je regarde sans cesse des choses autour
de moi je regarde une boîte de céréales
josy c'est comme ça que
je réfléchisse il faut que je trouve le
temps
de le traiter moi je peux paraître à 6
10 heures par jour je peux écrire
pendant 90 minutes dix ans de façon
intensive
parce que quand je suis dans un café
avec mon ordinateur je travaille pendant
une vitesse de mitrailleuses lourdes
c'est quoi ces d'où vient une bonne idée
et c'est comme ça que je comme
j'en arrive à ça parce qu'en tant que
journaliste vous êtes coincé dans un
dans un processus vous avez date butoir
un horaire butoir et c'est en temps réel
je me permet de travailler d'une façon
où les dates butoirs sont plus longues
ça me donne plus de temps pour réfléchir
et c'est une des meilleures décisions
que j'ai prises pour créer cet espace
parce que ça permet plus de
l'introspection qu'est-ce que je rate
les travailler avec un partenaire comme
pitau single c'est vraiment très utile
pour aimer cette question de où sont mes
billets qu'est-ce que je rate quelqu'un
qui est plus intelligente que vous c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'extraordinaire
dans un travail en équipe être capable
d'avoir une conversation connaître une
conversation de confiance et puis bon on
a une relation aussi amicale autant
qu'intellectuelle sait pas toujours le
cas parce que parfois il faut la force
de pouvoir le faire veillez à un niveau
fondamental de confiance et ça se
reflète dans la façon dont tu dont on
écrit quand vous lisez la flotte fantôme
si vous lisez contrôle vous pouvez pas
dire qui a écrit quoi parce que quand on
arrive à la fin on donne à l'autre notre
parti peut-être un chapitre peut-être
une page et l'autre à tous les droits de
le détruire totalement
et vraiment c'est un show extraordinaire
beaucoup d'auteurs ne peuvent pas le
faire parce qu'elle peut être trop de
deggo trop d'investissements dans les
mots dans les termes dans les phrases et
le fait d'avoir été un journaliste avoir
été
dont le travail a toujours été sabotés
par mes éditeurs ça me permet de
comprendre cette notion de croire au
processus
pour la confiance au processus j'étais
pas la meilleure idée a peut-être la
meilleure façon d'exprimer quelque chose
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
partenariat travail tellement bien et ça
se voit dans les bouquins parce que
c'est beaucoup de travail il nous reste
un peu de temps on n'a pas traité le
quart du dixième des questions je
voulais vous poser
faire revenir et je vous donne 10
minutes pour aborder un sujet avec nous
un sujet que vous souhaitez vous avez
envie de parler de quoi
si on veut parler de ce qu'on veut
et bien
[Musique]
je serai de comprendre
les grandes images
ce qui fonctionne au sein de la société
au sens plus large qu'est ce que nous en
tant qu individu pouvant faire le
changement
quelle est la volonté publique c'est
quoi la bonté public pas simplement
question tranquille mais comment est-ce
qu'on nous permette la technologie nous
permet de communiquer avec l'autre quels
sont les occasions que ça nous permet
d'avoir
de faire des réseaux pour faire des
flash mobs mais il ya un côté sombre
aussi
et ça peut être militarisé utilisé comme
arme
est-ce qu'on a un domaine aérien un
domaine de l'espace à domaine maritime
domaine terrestre
qu'est-ce qu'il est temps
le cyber bien sûr
qu'il est temps d'avoir un sixième
domaine un domaine cognitif à deux
mètres cubes
c'est vraiment une de mes réflexions
favorite
et c'est lié à la question de l'avancée
technologique
du déclin politique
de la nature changeante de la guerre
réussir mis littéralement
stratégiquement
sans déployer un seul soldat
c'est vraiment un aspect fascinant du
conflit au 21e siècle c'est suzhou
on a un beau 3 philosophe préféré
trois philosophes
for you le maire qui ont influencé votre
vie
genre je bouge sa
[Musique]
compagnie gibson
qui était un écrivain de science fiction
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui a
véritablement bercer le sable fin
et je le considérais comme philosophe
pas dans le sens de l'académie française
par exemple
c'est quelqu'un qui avait une façon
extrêmement réaliste
d'écrire ça va aider beaucoup quand
j'étais jeune à comprendre cet aspect de
la technologie
peut-être que c'est pas tous que c'était
censé être un peu comme dans les années
1980 en grandissant quand on voyait
l'avenir tout était propre
c'est tout était blanc riz thé jamais
salle et dans les rites dans l'est dans
les romans de gibson tout est
dégueulasse
c'est vraiment un aspect vital de la
façon dont on peut penser aux à l'avenir
un pur philosophe eric
philosophie des conflits armés
en lisant des textes et historique
classique
et je le fais avec des gens qui ne sont
pas spécialistes moi je n'ai pas utilisé
je n'ai pas étudié
mais en pensant aux conflits de l'avenir
c'est très important de voir ce qu'on a
établi les lois les lois fondamentales
des conflits
sur ce philosophe d'inspiration
finalement
c'est penser un autre écrivain et
probablement kim kardashian
de la guerre dit yves peut-être que ce
sera un général cinq étoiles de la
prochaine guerre
et
braderies écrivain de science fiction
américain
qui comme modem gipson a une approche
philosophique quasiment à la réflexion
pas simplement à l'avenir parce que
toutes ces histoires
ben c'était plus sur l'étrange sur
l'abstrait mais fondamentalement il n'a
jamais perdu de vue l'expérience humaine
dans la réalité alternative que l'on
pourrait avoir ou pas mais qui
affecterait fondamentalement le monde
dans lequel on vit j'ai regardé une
version filmée de faire l'âne à 2 451
qui était vraiment très très bien
mais j'ai relu le le roman il
fondamentalement ce qui est intéressant
dans ce livre c'était que montag le
pompier dans le but dont le boulot était
de brûler des livres commence à en
cacher sa relation avec sa femme est
vraiment très très troublante
très troublant pour comprendre le monde
son mentor est un des dissidents
un des bibliothèques en quelque sorte
qui travaillent à préserver le mot écrit
au dernier moment de cet aspect de
l'humanité où on brûle les livres et
c'est une méditation ex-amant profonde
sur cela signifie de partager le savoir
d'êtres humains ensemble parce que le
monde dans lequel vit montag est
déshumanisé totalement sais rien cdd
d'aider des reflets
ce que ray bradbury donne au lecteur
c'est de comprendre que comme pierre de
touche de la communauté passablement
delà de la civilisation c'est la
communauté comme on se comprend l'un
l'autre ça ça me parle j'ai jamais
réfléchi aussi profondément lorsque
j'étais jeune j'ai j'ai lu ça comme les
chroniques martiennes ou n'importe quoi
mais en écrivant c'est excessivement
important pour moi particulièrement
c'est ce roman là je vais vous poser une
question personnelle vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'y répondre je vois que vous
avez une alliance
votre partenaire qui doit vivre avec
vous tous les jours avec un cerveau qui
doit à mon avis phosphorer plus que la
moyenne avec un cerveau alimenté par des
sources de premièrement plus un instant
quand on voit que vous êtes ultra
sportif et que vous êtes addict à pas
l'adrénaline mais peut-être aux
endorphines sécrétées durant le le vtt
votre partenaire elles ou ils vous gère
comment
c'est une personnalité qui est
totalement différente de 1 elle a
développé un livre pour pouvoir gérer le
cerveau d'un analyste où il a développé
un livre pour servais pour pour gérer le
cerveau d'un analyste comment ça se
passe à la maison quand on a quatre
cerveau dans une seule boîte crânienne
a dit qu en fait peter c'est ma femme au
travail c'est mon épouse de travail on
passe tellement de temps mentalement et
vous savez même si on vit dans des
endroits éloignés les uns des autres on
n'est jamais loin l'un de l'autre
on se connaît mieux à travers le travail
et au cours de la commune c'était
important parce que
se reposait plus sur nos amis et c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire parce que
c'est quelque chose de très profond ce
quelque chose de personnel mais je crois
que
c'est merveilleux d'avoir ce niveau
d'amitié intellectuellement nos cerveaux
sont très différents
je comprends mieux mon esprit en
travaillant mais
d'avoir une conversation vraiment vrai
que les planifications jour est allé
directement vers les choses plus
importantes parle pas du processus
et pointe aveugle c'est le processus sur
un instinctif je vois quelque chose ça
m'intrigue je voudrais le prendre le
démonter le comprendre il intègre et
j'ai dû apprendre
la façon dont c'était difficile dans les
grands projets qui prennent des années
on peut pas faire ça impulsivement un
scintillement
ya un processus de logistique
et mon co auteur peter a écrit doctorat
il a l'expérience de l'écriture d'un
processus très important très
intéressant il ya un autre aspect de
cette personnalité qui est un de mes
autres pointes aveugle je suis pas très
bien dans la place bourget pas très bon
à la promotion je peux en parler un
pendant des heures mais mais quand on
comprend exactement ce que c'est d'être
un écrivain il faut être vraiment
économe comment comprendre
le marché de l'écriture et ça m'a
tellement aidé et ça c'est eux
c'est vraiment ce qu'il apporte de plus
à cette relation parce que moi je suis
pas aussi bon que ça je m'améliore mais
je dois travailler là dessus aussi et
vous
personnellement comment vous prenez la
passivité intellectuelle les gens que ce
soit vous cercle d'amis proches ou en
proche quand vous leur faites nrg des
prospectives qui sont réalistes mais
qu'il ne ce qui n'est pas bonne à
écouter ou à mâcher ou à ingérer quand
vous leur annoncer je vais pas vous je
veux pas dire l'apocalypse mais
pratiquement
de voir qu'il manque dans leurs yeux
cet éclair de lucidité qui leur
permettrait de comprendre la situation
vous personnellement comment vous gérez
ça
j'ai pas beaucoup d'amis
rien travaillé à washington
tout le monde est
véritablement très très engagé
très éduqué je vis à l'extérieur de
boston dans un monde différent
et j'aime ça parce que je peux dire à
quelqu'un ce que je fais il me dise quoi
tu fais quoi c'est un boulot ça
ce que ça vous force à faire et ça va
pas je dis pas ça de façon méprisante
un reflet dans le monde comprend la
chose
de la façon dont nous on travaille de la
façon dont nous on passe notre temps
c'est sa force une réflexion
je ne vois pas ça de façon c'est de
l'antipathie quand quelqu'un que je
parle à quelqu'un de la chine de la
guerre à venir qui ne comprend pas non
au lieu de ça
je sais plus de le comprendre qu'est ce
qui est important pour ces gens là
un truc d'écrivain les fans tentent de
comprendre ce qui se passe à l'avenir
j'écris pas des bouquins sur moi je peux
être un bouquin sur moi je vais écrire
un bouquin sur des vrais gens
tout le monde ne sera pas obsédé par les
chose qui m'obsède
être ouvert au niveau humain ça fait
partie de mon optimisme aussi c'est
essayer de rencontrer des gens tels
qu'ils sont si vous êtes à boston si
vous comptez vous conduisez à boston
vous pouvez haïr l'humanité il ya des
choses qui sont désespérants mais bon
sérieusement passer du temps avec des
gens les voir là où ils vivent je crois
que c'est une des meilleures choses que
l'on puisse faire on arrive à la fin
notre interview est-ce que vous pouvez
donner trois livres a conseillé à notre
communauté de 3,3 livre à recommander à
notre communautaire vous avez pas le
retenu les vôtres trois livres qui ont
influencé votre vie alors ça peut des
livres de géopolitique comme ça peut
être des contes pour enfants
trois livres a à z c'est bien
lire un livre sur l'amérique
c'est une trilogie
par john winslow à
souviens plus du nom du premier tour je
termine troisième
c'est la bonté de la narco économie au
mexique et aux etats-unis et on le suit
par un personnage unique qui est un
agent de la dea c'est à dire de l'office
anti drogue c'est vraiment
c'est trois romans 300 pages
le pouvoir du chien le cartel c'est le
deuxième tome le troisième c'est la
frontière et ça parle de toutes les
choses
de l'industrie de la drogue
à la corruption politique à la maison
blanche 1 c'est vrai c'est un vrai truc
est-ce que ça parle des opérations
spéciales des services américains pour
importer de la drogue pour pouvoir
financer des opérations spéciales ou pas
du tout
ça le fait
rend compte tout des contrats privés
militaire vraiment c'est il ya une
capacité de recherche il a écrit qu'un
16 romans non c'est un m
je dirais
je retournerais aussi à william gibson
que j'ai mentionnées précédemment
ces livres des plus anciens il y en a un
plus plus nouveau
situé aux états unis qui décrit une
amérique dystopique
plus d'automatisation mais qui parle
vraiment de
problème très important qui vient de
l'invention de
des tunnels quantique
et ses alertes de la science fiction
mais c'est plus que ça
c'est une histoire sur l'avenir
politique des états unis je recommande
grande qui
la suit said c'est le troisième
qui m'influence et
je lis tout le temps et quand j'étais
très jeune
je reviendrai ce que j'ai dit
le
deuxième
mais j'ai lu ce bouquin quand j'avais 12
ans ce qui est intéressant c'est que et
puis de sega a eu la même chose la même
expérience
prendre un bouquin est pas bouger
jusqu'à l'avoir terminé bon temps les
gamins je faisais ça et quand on écrit
la flotte fantôme
pour en revenir à relire ce livre pour
l'inspiration l'à beaucoup fait
c'était un moment
l'alpha et l'oméga
est en fait ce que je fais maintenant
c'est pas très différent de ce que je
pensais faire quand j'avais 15 16 ans
écrire des romans mais ces livres sont
très différents leach mais pour chacun
d'entre eux dans ce lot c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré comme comme
gibson qui pouvaient
traiter de ces choses extrêmement
complexe et emprunte ses c'est vraiment
la première graine qui étaient plantés
en moi est-ce que vous avez vu ce film
si mes souvenirs sont bons c'est doit
être newsroom est-ce que vous avez vu
quand un journaliste on lui pose la
question l'auditoire lui pose la
question pourquoi l'amérique est le plus
beau pays du monde
vous ce film-là
et de ce film non non non je n'ai pas vu
alors moi je vais vous poser la question
différemment pourquoi l'amérique n'est
pas le plus n'est plus le plus beau pays
du monde où
l'enseignement
pourquoi ça ne l'est plus
notre incapacité de prendre soin les uns
des autres au niveau humain c'est pas le
niveau politique on n'a cessé de
s'occuper les uns des autres c'est ce à
l'origine c'est pas une question de
doctrine
c'est nos divisions sont exploités
chaque jour au niveau politique
et c'est
presque un message chrétien mais on
devrait pouvoir le faire mieux
si on pense à notre avenir un lieu où
les gens voudraient vivre et avoir des
enfants il faut régler ce problème là la
dernière question c'est pas une question
s'est laissé une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose d'impérissables un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
je souhaite voir j'aimerais bien savoir
un aphorisme
je pense à cette conversation avec ma
fille
s'occupait des gens prendre soin des
gens
chaque fois que l'on doit prendre une
décision difficile c'est comment prendre
soin d'eux quelqu'un d'autre quand on
réfléchit aux décisions qu'on prend dans
la vie il faut y vivre qui font en vivre
avec ça 1 c'est des choses qui ne vienne
dans la nuit des choses qui vient dans
la journée il était important de prendre
des décisions même quand on prend des
mauvaises décisions il faut vivre avec
après
et si on peut revenir sains principes
tels que celui là et je sais que ça va
avoir l'air un petit peu
concon quoi et ça une qualité
profonde
peut pas avoir peur quand tellement des
gens
veulent nous déchirer et bien c'est ça
il faut prendre soin les uns des autres
la façon dont je je lève ma fille
quelqu'un qui aimeraient prendre des
risques mais quelqu'un qui aimeraient
aussi qui voudra savoir comment prendre
soin des autres et c'est pas facile
auguste cool merci
c'est moi que je vous remercie beaucoup
[Musique]
com